le tribunal de new york a rendu public
lundi les détails d'un accord de
règlement signé il ya 13 ans entre
virginia roberts et des fripes style on
apprend qu'à l'époque la jeune femme
voulait entamer des poursuites
judiciaires envers le millionnaire
qu'elle accusait de l'avoir exploité et
agressé sexuellement la plusieurs
reprises alors qu'elle était adolescente
mais cette poursuite ne s'est jamais
concrétisée le 17 novembre 2009 jeffrey
hangst il conclu une entente avec la
présumée victime il lui offre 500 mille
dollars
virginia roberts s'engage alors à garder
le silence il refuse toute poursuite
judiciaire envers l'entourage de
jefferies obstine au mois d'août 2021
virginia roberts revient devant les
tribunaux et accuse le prince andrew de
l'avoir agressée sexuellement à
plusieurs reprises au début des années
2000 alors qu'elle avait 17 ans et sous
l'emprise de jeffrey epstein
affirme-t-elle les audiences doivent
commencer mardi à new york la justice
américaine va examiner la validité de la
plainte le prince n jouve rejette
catégoriquement les allégations
ses avocats affirment que l'accord signé
en 2009 le protège contre certaines
réclamations et constituera un motif
suffisant pour le rejet de la poursuite
rappelons que jeff probst in a été
arrêté et accusé d'avoir agressé
sexuellement des dizaines de jeunes
filles au début des années 2000 un mois
plus tard il est mort dans sa cellule
sans avoir eu à faire face à la justice
sa complice de l'époque ghislaine
maxwell a été reconnu coupable de trafic
sexuel la semaine dernière à new york
ici marie michèle osant radio canada
montréal